en este vídeo quiero trabajar un poquito
a partir de lo que hicimos en el vídeo
pasado entonces supongamos que tenemos
dos variables aleatorias xy aquí a la
izquierda voy a poner la variable
aleatoria x y voy a dibujar su
distribución de probabilidad que no
tiene por qué verse como una
distribución normal pero la voy a
dibujar así luego por aquí voy a marcar
la media de x ba la media poblacional
muy su x ok además tiene una cierta
desviación estándar pero sabes que
déjame enfocarme más bien en la varianza
entonces tiene cierta varianza sigma x
cuadrada y déjame poner pues por aquí en
algún lugar que esta es la variable a
thor ya x y además de ésta tenemos otra
variable aleatoria ye muy bien vamos a
hacer exactamente lo mismo vamos a
dibujar su distribución de probabilidad
nos quedaría algo de este estilo y por
aquí tiene su media su media
muxu bien su media de población
y además tiene una cierta varianza sigma
subió al cuadrado
muy bien ok otra vez la dibujé más o
menos normal pero no tenemos que asumir
que es normal porque pues después cuando
pasemos al siguiente nivel y tomemos
muchas muestras gracias al teorema del
límite central vamos a poder olvidarnos
de eso pero bueno con eso dicho vamos a
pensar en las distribuciones muestrales
de cada una de estas variables
aleatorias vamos a empezar con la
distribución muestral con la
distribución muestral de la media
muestral de x la media muestral de x ok
vamos a suponer que el tamaño de la
muestra que el tamaño de la muestra es
igual a n ok
acá no sabes que voy a seguir con el
lado izquierdo para acabar con el verde
entonces va a tener cierta distribución
que pues como en es muy muy grande se va
a ver con una distribución normal va
entonces se va a aparecer a una
distribución normal observa que está un
poquito más flaquita no sabes que déjame
hacer un dibujo un poco más a la derecha
más o menos algo así entonces la voy a
dibujar un poco más flaquita por el
teorema del límite central que nos dice
que la desviación estándar de esta
distribución a ver primero déjame
dibujar la media entonces la media de la
distribución muestral mushuk x barra así
la vamos a denotar esta de aquí es la
media de la distribución muestral para
el tamaño de muestra en esta ya sabemos
que es igual a la media de la población
va esto de aquí es algo que ya hicimos
varias veces y además por el teorema del
límite central sabemos que la varianza
que sigma sub equis barra al cuadrado o
bien el error estándar es otra cosa
verdad ahorita paso a eso es igual a la
varianza poblacional a sigma sube x al
cuadrado dividido entre el tamaño de la
muestra entonces es dividido entre n lo
voy a poner en rosa mexicana
muy bien ahora si quisiéramos la
desviación estándar o el error estándar
hay que tomar la raíz cuadrada de ambos
lados vamos a hacer lo mismo con la
variable aleatoria y entonces del otro
lado tenemos otra vez la distribución
muestral la distribución muestral de la
media muestral pero ahora es la media
muestral de la variable aleatoria y ok
supongamos que tenemos un tamaño de
muestra distinto no tiene que ser el
mismo que el anterior vamos a ponerle
que tiene un tamaño de muestra de pues
no sé digamos
m
ok voy a dibujar por acá la distribución
y algo de este estilo una vez más se va
a parecer a una normal y va a estar
medio flaquita por aquí tiene una cierta
media entonces la media muestral es
decir muchos sub de barra pues una vez
más la media de la distribución muestral
va a ser igual a la media poblacional va
a ser igual a muy sub esto es algo que
ya hemos visto una y otra vez y ahora
pasemos a la varianza es decir vamos a
poner la varianza de su barra o sea de
la media muestral hay que ponerle un
cuadrado verdad para que sea la varianza
si no le pusiéramos el cuadrado entonces
sería el error estándar o bien la
desviación estándar eso es lo que deje
pendiente hace rato entonces si quieres
encontrar el error estándar hay que
sacarle la raíz a la varianza pero bueno
no quiero confundirte la varianza de la
media muestral ya la vamos a obtener con
la misma idea lo que tenemos que hacer
es tomar la varianza poblacional sigma
subiera al cuadrado y dividirlo entre el
tamaño de la muestra
/ / m muy bien hasta ahorita todo lo que
hemos hecho ha sido más que nada un
repaso de hecho hasta un repaso doble
pero no creas que me saque de la manga
eso de las dos variables la razón de
esto es que vamos a hacer lo siguiente
vamos a definir una nueva variable
aleatoria a esta nueva variable
aleatoria le voy a poner pues no sé
digamos le voy a poner zeta ceta va a
ser igual a la diferencia de las medias
muestrales vale entonces ésta va a ser
igual a equis barra déjame ponerlo con
los colores que corresponden z va a ser
igual a equis barra menos llevar menos
llevar entonces qué quiere decir z pues
saber para obtener una media muestral
para la distribución de x lo que estamos
haciendo es tomar en de muestras
distribuidas según x es decir n muestras
de la población por ejemplo si en es
igual a 10
tomamos 10 muestras las promediamos y
eso de ahí sería la media muestral que
supongamos que nos quedan 9.2 otra forma
de pensarlo es que
9.2 viene como una muestra de la
distribución muestral lo mismo pasa con
ya digamos si m es igual pues no sé si
es igual a 12 y tomamos 12 muestras de
iu y las promediamos entonces al obtener
una media muestral de digamos 15.2 lo
podemos pensar como una muestra de la
distribución de la media muestral qué
cosas no pero bueno entonces lo que
quiere decir z o bueno la forma en la
cual podemos pensar a z es en la
siguiente primero tomamos n muestras de
la población de x y las promediamos
luego tomamos m muestras de la población
de jay y también las promediamos
finalmente hacemos la resta entre estos
promedios y eso nos da una nueva
variable aleatoria entonces una buena
pregunta es cómo es la distribución de z
pues hay algunas cositas que ya sabemos
acerca de z voy a dibujarla pero en tres
de esos sabes que antes de eso pues nos
conviene trabajar un poquito con su
media y con su varianza esto es algo que
hicimos en el vídeo pasado entonces la
media de z en vez de ponerse está voy a
poner simplemente x barra pero con los
colores que cobres
entonces musa x barra y para dejar bien
claro qué pasa aquí lo que queremos es
la media de la diferencia de las medias
muestrales de xy de y entonces aquí va
mucho peques barra menos llevar esto es
igual a pues algo que ya habíamos hecho
desde antes de saber si lo tengo por
aquí si aquí está lo que ya habíamos
hecho en el vídeo pasado vimos que pues
esto de acá que la media de la
diferencia de unas variables aleatorias
es la diferencia de las medias vamos a
pasar esto para acá abajo entonces la
media de la diferencia de las medias
muestrales es igual a voy a agarrar los
colores que corresponden la media de x
barra menos la media
la media de llevar hasta ahorita todo se
ve muy abstracto pero en el siguiente
vídeo vamos a hacer un ejemplo con
numeritos pues para acabar de fijar las
ideas a lo mejor es un buen momento para
decir que la gran gracia de esto que
estamos haciendo es que eventualmente
vamos a poder hacer inferencias
estadísticas acerca de la diferencia de
las medias muestrales con intervalos de
confianza y otras herramientas que hemos
acumulado pues vamos a ver si es
razonable que tenga ciertos
comportamientos bueno regresando a lo
que estábamos entonces sabemos que la
media de la diferencia de estas medias
muestrales es lo que acabamos de
escribir pasemos ahora a la varianza
otra vez en el vídeo anterior ya
habíamos trabajado la varianza de la
diferencia de dos variables aleatorias
la gran lección de ese vídeo es que no
era la diferencia de las varianzas sino
la suma de las varianzas bueno pasemos a
esa gran enseñanza a esto que estamos
trabajando ahorita la varianza de esta
distribución que ni siquiera he dibujado
ahorita a la dibujo entonces la varianza
de esta nueva distribución de x barra
menos de barra va a ser igual a la suma
de las varianzas
a sigma cuadrada de x barra + sigma
cuadrada de barra ahora sí déjame
dibujar la distribución de probabilidad
para que vayamos visualizando las cosas
después vamos a pasar estos parámetros
en términos de los parámetros originales
de la equis y de la jr entonces por aquí
queda la media déjame indicar la por acá
abajo por aquí queda la media y se llama
la media de x barra menos de barra y eso
es igual a la diferencia de las medias
pero ahorita no quiero reescribir lo
bueno entonces la distribución de
probabilidad quedaría más o menos algo
de este estilo así como una normal y
observa que aquí ya quedó un poquito más
gruesa la normal la razón es que ahora
la varianza es la suma de las varianzas
de este modo las muestras ya no van a
quedar tan cerquita del centro su
varianza es mayor
déjame indicar por aquí la varianza
sigma sub x menos ibarra al cuadrado
ahora como cambiamos estos parámetros a
las medias y varianzas originales pues
eso es justo lo que estuvimos trabajando
aquí
por ejemplo conocemos la varianza de x
barra sabemos que esta cosa de aquí que
está varianza sigma sub x barra es esto
que escribimos aquí arriba es la
varianza poblacional dividido entre el
tamaño de la muestra de hecho aquí ya lo
hicimos varias veces entonces la
igualdad nos queda a ver es esta parte
de aquí que es la varianza de nuestra
población verdad sigma al cuadrado
verdad hay que ponerle el subíndice x
para acordarnos que viene de equis y
aquí ya no tiene barra esto de aquí es
la varianza de la población no de la
muestra ahora eso lo tenemos que dividir
entre n y luego si queremos la varianza
de la distribución muestral de y déjame
hacerlo con otro color
voy a hacerlo con color azul por
consistencia entonces la varianza es
igual a esta expresión que obtuvimos es
la misma lógica que en el primer sumando
entonces queda la varianza poblacional
para y dividido entre el tamaño de
nuestra muestra es decir nos queda
dividido entre m queda dividido entre m
excelente
recapitular déjame volver a escribir a
la izquierda la varianza
entonces esta es una fórmula para la
varianza de la diferencia de las medias
muestrales ahora si quisiéramos
encontrar la desviación estándar de la
diferencia de las medias muestrales
tendríamos que sacar una raíz cuadrada
haciendo esto nos quedaría que la
desviación estándar de la diferencia de
las medias muestrales es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de pues saber la varianza
poblacional si la varianza poblacional
de x dividido entre n y luego tenemos
que sumarle tenemos que sumarle la
varianza la varianza poblacional del
dividido entre m la gran gracia de
sacarle una raíz es que ahora aparece
una fórmula de distancia lo cual está
padre conforme vayamos recorriendo
nuestro camino con la estadística
vamos a ir agarrando más herramientas
para entender pues bien bien en el fondo
qué quiere decir esto antes de eso
retomemos lo que acabamos de hacer
gracias a esto ahora podemos hacer
inferencias de diferencias de muestras o
sea si tomamos dos medias muestrales y
las restamos ahora podemos preguntarnos
por qué tan probable fue que
obtuviéramos el valor que obtuvimos
voy a hacer un ejemplo concreto en el
siguiente vídeo hasta la próxima